THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARILLO
SERVAN SAYS
CHAU. CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY. COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM
DAHLE. DALY. EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY. GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY. LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON. LOW. MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI. NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA REYES
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH STONE. THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON. WEBER WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVENUE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO BRING BACK AN
INVENTOR AND ENGINEER OR
SCIENTIST
FROM FIVE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. OR THREE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
I THINK THEY WOULD THEY WOULD
MARVEL AT THE INCREDIBLE CHANGES
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE.
AN ENGINEER OR SCIENTIST MIGHT.
GAPED IN DISBELIEF AT THE
TECHNOLOGY WE LIVE WITH EACH
DAY.
AMAZED AT ALL THAT WE SO EASILY
TAKE FOR GRANTED.
BUT IF WE BROUGHT BACK A
POLITICAL PHILOSOPHER. SOCRATES
TRUNKS WHO ROOMY.
THEY WOULD PROBABLY LOOK OUT.
AT THE HUMAN CONDITION TODAY AND
SAY.
NO CHANGE.
WE HUMAN BEINGS ARE STILL LIVING
WITH FEAR AND SUPERSTITION.
DIVISIVENESS IN HATE.
GREED SELFLESSNESS AND BIGOTRY.
STILL WARS PROCESS AND STILL THE
INNOCENT ARE THE CASUALTIES.
STILL POWER ENTICES CORRUPTION
AND STILL THE ON EMPOWERED AND
DISENFRANCHISED ARE THE VICTIMS.
IN DESPAIR. YOU MIGHT EASY THE
WONDER HAVE WE HUMAN BEINGS
LEARN NOTHING IN ALL THE
CENTURIES.
HOWEVER ON FURTHER OBSERVATION.
I HOPED HE WOULD SEE THAT THERE
IS STILL DEEP CARING AND
COMPASSION.
THAT THE HEART OF HUMAN KINDNESS
STILL BEAT STRONGLY WITHIN MORE
PEOPLE THAN EVER BEFORE.
AS THE DALAI LAMA HAS SAID.
COMPASSIONATE ACTIVITIES ARE SO
MUCH A PART OF OUR DAILY LIFE.
DID THEY ARE TAKEN FOR GRANTED
AND THEREFORE LARGELY IGNORED.
I FEEL THAT THE WISE
PHILOSOPHERS IN THE INSIGHTFUL
PUTS FROM THROUGHOUT HUMAN
HISTORY. WOULD SEE THAT THERE IS
TODAY OF REACHING OUT TO NURTURE
HOPE IN RECENT ON A GLOBAL
SCALE.
AND THEY WOULD BE PLEASED AND
RELIEVED
SEE. THAT WE HAVE NEVER STOPPED
TRYING.
CREATE A BETTER FUTURE FOR THE
GENERATIONS TO COME.
NUMBER ONE WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GLORIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME PLEASE MAKES OUR
FLAG READY BEGIN.
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
STATE.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
ONE.
IT IS.
THERE IS A AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
FOURTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN BEE
SEMI MINUTES SEVEN A. M. ON BILL
BRIAN DAHLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FIRST DISTRICT PRESIDING CHIEF
CLERK E. DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK. EXISTING QUICK DAVID A
BERMAN READING THE FOLLOWING A
PLACE ON THE MORNING ROLL CALL
ACOSTA AGUIAR CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
AND THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM WOOD.
FOR A FUNERAL AND DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A.
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI AND BONTA HAVE TO TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY THE GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT THE MEMBERS DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS EGGMAN JONES SAWYER
MATHIS TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO WITHDRAW I SEE ARE SEVENTY
FOUR WIENER FROM APPROPRIATIONS
AND ORDER THE RESOLUTION TWO
THIRDS. THIRD READING AS THE
RESOLUTION IS NOT FISCAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THERE IS A LETTER AT THE DESK
RELATIVE TO AB SIXTY NINETY FOUR
BY MISTER STONE. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS NEED UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO PRINT THE LETTER IN THE
JOURNAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY THIRTY SIX GIPSON FROM
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
ONE A TWO RODRIGUEZ FROM THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY ONE TEN EGGMAN FROM
THEIR NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY FRIEDMAN
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FOUR RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY BURKE FROM
THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE TING
FROM THE NOT TO RESOURCE
COMMITTEE TO THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK
TO THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED BURKE FROM THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY RADIUS
FROM THE HUMAN RESOURCES
COMMITTEE.
EXCUSE ME TO THAT FROM THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN GRAYSON FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
AND THEN BACK TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE AND. A. B.
THIRTY TWO ó SEVEN LIMON FROM
THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE PRIVACY CAN'T
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
AND THEN BACK TO THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL
SIXTY TWO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT. TO OUT LOUD THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
WINE TO MEET JOINTLY WITH THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON WINE
ON FRIDAY APRIL SIXTH AT TEN AM.
AT HELZBERG CITY HALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
MEMBERS
A SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT.
OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOSE MEDINA CELEBRATED HIS SIXTY
FIFTH BIRTHDAY LAST THURSDAY
LET'S GIVE HIM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR HIS
VIP INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'M SUPER EXCITED TO
HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY MY NINE
YEAR OLD SON. ANDREAS BONTA
WHO'S IN THIRD GRADE AND
SPENDING THE DAY WITH US TODAY.
AND DOCTOR SPENDING THE DAY WITH
US FOR ALAMEDA SO I THINK YOU
OFFER WHAT WELCOMING HIM SO
WARMLY HE'S EXCITED TO BE HERE
TODAY. YOU KNOW IF
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI ALSO
HAS GUESTS WITH US SPECIAL
GUESTS ON THE FLOOR TODAY MISTER
MERCY G..
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO MY TWO BOSSES.
DOCTOR HERE OKAY GOOD SEE MY
WIFE AND KEIKO MURATSUCHI MY
DAUGHTER
AND MEMBERS WE ARE CELEBRATING
BIRTHDAYS.
MEMBERS TODAY'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID SHOES BIRTHDAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. MR CHIO
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT SECOND
READING.
CLERK WILL READ.
I SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
THREE TWENTY SIXTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S TWENTY NINETY NINE
WITH THE MEMONS TWENTY ONE
THIRTY ONE AT THE MOMENT
SEVENTEEN NINETY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
AT THE MOMENTS TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WITH THE
MEMONS TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY FORTY SEVEN
WITH THE MEMONS NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WITH THE MEMONS. TWENTY
NINETY SEVEN WITH THE MOMENT
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE WITH THE
MOMENTS TWENTY SEVENTY WITH THE
MOMENT AND NINETEEN FOURTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
ON RECONSIDERATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER APART ME ITEMS FILE ITEMS
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE.
WILL BE CONTINUED.
WE ARE IN ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TO PASS AND
RETAIN.
WHEN TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE HR
EIGHTY SIX.
FILE ITEMS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX.
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WHERE IT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
DOWN ON THE CHAMBER WE HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE BODY WHERE
FILE AND TWENTY SEVEN A. B..
NINETEEN OH EIGHT AND THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBL BILL NINETEEN ó EIGHT
BY SOME A MEMBER CAVEZ AND
ACTUALLY THE MEMORIAL DISTRICTS.
MISTER CHAVEZ YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
I'M SURE YOU READ IN THE PAPER
OVER THE WEEKEND ALL THE.
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE VA. AND
ABOUT THE VA SECRETARY LEAVING
AND WHAT REALLY DO VETERANS
NEED.
ONE THING I'VE LEARNED IN
WORKING WITH VETERANS THE BEST
WAY TO DEAL WITH VETERANS IS
INDIVIDUALLY WITH IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MOVE
RESOURCES TO HELP YOUR VETERANS.
A. B. NINETEEN NO WAIT DOES
EXACTLY THAT.
IT WOULD INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
AND OVERSIGHT FROM FINANCE
REPORTS FILED BY VETERAN
MEMORIAL DISTRICTS.
TO IDENTIFY DISBURSEMENTS MADE
PROVIDERS OF VETERAN SUPPORT OF
SERVICE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
TO TAKE CARE OF YOUR VETERANS
WITHIN YOUR DISTRICT.
THANK YOU QUESTION CHáVEZ.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ISLAND BEFORE THE BODY.
CLARK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS OUT OF VOTE
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLE.
AND HOW YOU VOTE.
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ADAMS TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE.
AND THIRTY.
PASS A RETAIN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
ONE.
THAT IT'S A SEA ARE ONE NINETY
EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE NINETY EIGHT BY SEVEN MEMBER
JONES SAWYER RELATIVE TO DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
ACR ONE NINE EIGHT.
RECOGNIZES APRIL FOURTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY. OF THE
ASSASSINATION OF DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
EVEN THOUGH WE MARK THIS AS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ASSASSINATION
WE REALLY NEED TO RECOGNIZE.
THIS AS DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR MAKING THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE FOR THE FIGHT FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS.
HE GAVE HIS LIFE.
THE FACT THAT DOCTOR KING
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THE GREAT INJUSTICES THAT HE SAW
AND WITNESS FIRSTHAND. KNOWING
THAT THERE WERE MULTIPLE THREATS
TO HIS LIFE IS THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF TRUE SACRIFICE.
EVEN AS WORDS CLEARLY SHOWED HIS
COMMITMENT TO FIGHTING FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS REGARDLESS OF HIS SAFETY.
THERE COMES A TIME WHEN ONE MUST
TAKE A POSITION THAT IS NEITHER
SAFE.
NOR POLITIC
NO POPULAR BUT HE MUST TAKE IT
BECAUSE CONSCIENCE TELLS HIM. IT
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
WORSE SAID SHOULD RESONATE IN
OUR CONSCIOUSNESS AS WE COME
WITNESSES TO CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS THAT WOULD HAVE
STIRRED DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FIFTY YEARS AGO.
YOUNG BLACK.
ON ARE MEN BEING EXECUTED.
BY POLICE OFFICERS BLACK AND
BROWN CHILDREN NOT BEING ABLE TO
READ AT THIRD GRADE LEVEL.
NINETY EIGHT PERCENT OF OUR
INCARCERATED YOUTH BEING BLACK
AND BROWN BOYS AND YOUNG MEN.
I AM SURE THAT THESE ATROCITIES
WOULD HAVE MADE DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING CONTINUE TO SPEAK
OUT WITHOUT FEAR. I CONTINUE TO
PEACEFUL PURSUIT OF JUSTICE
KNOWING THAT HE MIGHT NOT GET TO
THE PROMISED LAND.
MEMBERS AS WE COMMEMORATE DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
ASSASSINATIONLET US SEE IT FOR
THE GREAT SACRIFICE THAT ANY
THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD MAN. CAN
MAKE WITH A WIFE AND FOUR
CHILDREN.
WHO?
IN TWELVE YEARS WAS ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH SO MUCH BECOME A
WORLD RENOWNED CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS.
MEMBERS MY CHALLENGE TO EACH OF
YOU IS WHAT KIND OF SACRIFICE
ARE WE WILLING TO MAKE. AN OUR
TWELVE YEAR TERMS IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
AS CHAIR OF THE PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IS MY PRIVILEGE AND HONOR
TO AUTHOR ACR ONE NINETY EIGHT
TO CELEBRATE THE WORK OF A GREAT
LEADER. A MAN WHO IS WILLING TO
SACRIFICE
SAFETY AND ULTIMATELY HIS LIFE
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE MEMBERS SPEAKER PLEASE MAKE
THE FIRST ROLL CALL OPEN FOR
COAL AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MS JONES SAWYER MISTER
GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF ACR. ONE NINETY
EIGHT AND THANK THE AUTHOR THE
LOS ANGELES RING THIS RESOLUTION
BEFORE US TODAY.
DOCTOR MARTIN KING JUNIOR WAS A
REVOLUTIONARY AND HIS APPROACH
TO FIGHTING.
FOR JUSTICE.
BUT I'M SADDENED.
THAT WE CONTINUE.
THE SAME BECAUSE THE DOCTOR KING
CHAMPION. OVER FIFTY YEARS AFTER
HIS ASSASSINATION.
BLACK VOICE.
AND GIRLS.
DALY FACE EXTREME ADVERSITIES.
WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO
EDUCATION.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
RESOURCES.
IN ADDITION TO MASSIVE
INCARCERATION AND VIOLENCE.
AND IN SPITE OF THIS.
WE AND REYES DOCTOR KING'S
NONVIOLENT APPROACH.
EVEN WHEN FACED WITH SITUATIONS
AS GRAVE VIOLENCE AS THEY ARE
TODAY.
AND WE CONTINUE TO STRIVE FOR A
WORLD.
WHICH PEOPLE ARE JUDGED BY THE
CONTENT OF THE CHARACTER AND NOT
THE COLOR. OF THEIR SKIN.
BUT AS WE SEEN IN RECENT EVENTS.
OUR WORK IS FAR FROM OVER
SACRAMENTO.
OUR WORK IS FAR FROM OVER LOS
ANGELES.
OUR WORK IS FAR FROM OVER.
OAKLAND COMPTON LONG BEACH.
DOCTOR KING SAID.
INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A THREAT
TO JUTICE EVERYWHERE.
SO TODAY WE HONOR THE MEMORY.
A DOCTOR KING'S LEGACY IN HIS
COMMITMENT TO ALWAYS REACHING
TOWARDS.
THE PROMISED LAND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I BOATS
OUT ACR ONE NINETY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS ASSET THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THIS IS HER COAUTHORS MEMBERS.
COOPER SONNY SEE ARE ONE NINETY
EIGHT.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO.
THIS IS ACR TWO OH SIX THE
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO GO SIX BY SOMETHING NUMBER
HOLDEN AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE CALIFORNIA DIVERSITY IN STEM
ATTACK WEEK.
MR HOLDING YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I STAND TO REPRESENT AND PRESENT
ACR ZERO SIX DIVERSE IN
TECHNOLOGY IN COLLABORATION WITH
MY FELLOW CAUCUS TEARS. OR
HELPING TO BRING ATTENTION TO
SUCH A CRITICAL ISSUE AND OUR
NATION.
A SIGNIFICANT DIVERSITY GAP
EXISTS IN PREPARATION AND
PARTICIPATION AND STEM
DISCIPLINES AND THE TECHNOLOGY
WORKFORCE.
THERE'S MASS UNDER
REPRESENTATION IN THE TECH
INDUSTRY WITH LESS THAN TWO
PERCENT. OF ANY MINORITY GROUP
AND TECHNICAL ROLES.
AND THE TOP SEVENTY FIVE
COMPANIES IN SILICON VALLEY ONLY
THREE PERCENT EMPLOYEES ARE
BLOCK.
ACCORDING TO THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION.
DIVERSITY IS NOT SIMPLY ABOUT
FILLING SEATS AT THE TABLE BUT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT HAVING A VOICE
IN MAKING DECISIONS AT THE
TABLE.
THE LEGISLATURES GOAL IS TO
MINIMIZE THE DIVERSITY GAP IN
AMERICA'S WORKFORCE AND DEDICATE
APRIL FIRST. THROUGH APRIL
SEVENTH. OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS CALIFORNIA DIVERSITY
AND STEM AND TECH WEEK.
A DIVERSE TECH INDUSTRY HELPS
ENSURE THAT THEIR PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES MEET THE DIVERSE NEEDS
OF THE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
DEPEND ON THEM.
IT ALSO HELPS COMPANIES AVOID.
UP PER PET TEMPERATURE
PERPETRATING RACIAL BIAS.
AND DISCRIMINATION WHICH POSE
LEGAL FINANCIAL AND REPUTATIONAL
RISKS TO THEM.
WE ALMOST MAKE TECH DIVERSITY A
PRIORITY ESPECIALLY IF WE WANT
TO SEE A CHANGE IN THE TREND
THAT IS BEFORE US TODAY.
WE CAN'T BE PRODUCTIVE AND
PROTECTIVE.
OF PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRODUCED RESULTS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
EVEN IF THEY HAVE PRODUCED SOME
JOBS SOME JOBS ARE NOT ENOUGH.
ACR TWO OH SIX RAISES AWARENESS
IN SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATH.
AND THE NEED TO INTENSELY
DIVERSIFY THE TECH INDUSTRY.
AS LAWMAKERS WE CANNOT SIT ON
THE SIDELINES AND HOPE THAT WE
ARE GAINING MORE PEOPLE OF
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS.
THE TECHNOLOGY
TODAY LETTUCE EAGERLY FIGHT TO
CHANGE THE LACK OF DIVERSITY TO
OUR FUTURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE AND ASK THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
MR LOW.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
DID YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
AS CO CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
TECH CAUCUS IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE COMPANIES
WERE TO INCREASE DIVERSITY. AND
EQUITY IN THEIR WORKFORCE OF ALL
LEVELS INCLUDING IN EXECUTIVE
AND BOARD POSITIONS
IN ORDER FOR THESE COMPANIES TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE DIVERSE TALENT
POOL AND EMPLOYMENT OUR
CHILDREN.
AND YOUNG PEOPLE NEED TO BE
EXPOSED TO THESE CRITICAL
COURSES IN SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATH AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
A THIS IS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF STEM AND.
DIVERSITY IN TECH AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS LOVE.
MISTER BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS THE CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN A CO
AUTHOR. OF ACR I TO A SIX I RISE
IN SUPPORT CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
SOME OF THE MOST ICONIC AND
DYNAMIC TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES. IN
THE WORLD.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT THESE
COMPANIES WORK TO INCREASE THE
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY OF THEIR
WORK FORCE ON ALL LEVELS
INCLUDING. AN EXECUTIVE LEVEL
POSITIONS
WHILE IT MAY APPEAR THAT ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE WELL REPRESENTED
IN STEM THERE ARE DISPARITIES IN
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS WITHIN THE
DIVERSE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER. COMMUNITIES
IN ORDER FOR THESE COMPANIES TO
pTALENT POOL FOR EMPLOYMENT OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS NEED
TO BE EXPOSED TO CRITICAL
COURSES. IN STEM ACR TWO OH SIX
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
STEM AND DIVERSE CITY IN TECH
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA
SEEN NO DITION ALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS ASSET THE FIRST ROLE
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL. OPEN THEIR OWN MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
TWO OF SIX.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX
COAUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
HOSEIN A.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY RELATIVE TO
THIS RESOLUTION.
STERN BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY
AND WELCOME IN A GROUP OF
STUDENTS FROM SACRAMENTO'S. CAL
MIDDLE SCHOOL THEY'RE HERE IN
THE GALLERY TODAY THEY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE PART IN A
STEM EXPERIENCE IN AUGMENTED
REALITY AND VIRTUAL REALITY
WHICH INCLUDED A SECTION ON
CREATING THEIR OWN. VIRTUAL
REALITY EXPERIENCE IS EXPOSURE
TO EXPERIENCES LIKE THESE WHICH
WILL BE MORE AND MORE STUDENTS
TO CHOOSE FIELDS AND STEM AND
ULTIMATELY A CAREER AND
TECHNOLOGY PLEASE GIVE THEM A
WARM WELCOME.
MISTER KILEY ARE RECOGNIZE YOU
ALSO HAVE GUESTS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
JOINING THOSE STUDENTS IN THE
AUGMENTED AND VIRTUAL REALITY
EXPERIENCE.
WHERE SOME STUDENTS FROM MY
DISTRICT FROM?
DRY CREEK JOINT ELEMENTARY AND
MY OWN ALMA MATER CABBAGE IN
YOUR HIGH PLEASE JOIN ME IN
GIVING THE STUDENTS ASWELL A
VERY WARM WELCOME
.
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE HAS PASSED TO
RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK.
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THREE.
AND THAT ITS HR.
EIGHTY SIX.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE RELATIVE
TO SAYS ARE CHAVEZ DAY.
MR SOLACE YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS
TODAY RISE RESENT HR EIGHTY
SIXTH COMMEMORATE THE BIRTH AND
LEGACY OF.
CAESAR CHAVEZ THIS PAST WEEK
MANY CALIFORNIANS AND JOY TO
MAKE AN EXTENDED WEEKEND IN
HONOR OF HIS TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE. AND
THE SPIRIT OF HIS WORK
PARTICIPATING AND SERVICE
PROJECTS IN COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE.
CESAR CHAVEZ'S LIFE IS OF
PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE TO ME IN
MY DISTRICT.
BECAUSE IT WAS IN THE LANE OF
THAT CAESAR ALONGSIDE A
DEDICATED GROUP OF ACTIVISTS
BEGAN TO BUILD THE FARM WORKER
MOVEMENT.
MEMBERS OF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
MEMBERS.
IS GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MISTER
SOLACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY. YOU
KNOW GROWING UP WE WOULD LEARN
AND WE WOULD SEE CESAR CHAVEZ
AND HIS TEACHINGS OF HARD WORK.
SELF SACRIFICE AND PERSEVERANCE
I REMEMBER AS A KID.
ME AND MY SISTER HEARING THE
STORIES FROM OUR LOVED ONES
ABOUT CAESAR IN THE UFW.
AND SEEING THE MARCH IS
HAPPENING IN FRONT OF OUR HOMES
AND IN OUR LOCAL PARKS.
AT THE TIME THERE WERE MANY
DEBATES ABOUT WHAT THE MOVEMENT
WAS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
AND WHO WAS HELPING INTO IT
WASN'T.
WE SAW AND HEARD ABOUT THE
ORGANIZING A FARM WORKERS IN THE
FIELDS.
WE LEARNED ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE MONONGAH UNION A
FILIPINO AMERICAN WORKERS NOW
CESAR CHAVEZ AND LARIAT LONG.
FOUGHT HARD FOR BETTER WORKING
CONDITIONS AND BETTER PAY.
WE LEARNED ABOUT THE
UNPRECEDENTED THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILE MARCH.
FROM DELANO TO THE CAPITAL AND
THE EVENTUAL PAT EVENTUALLY.
THE PASSING OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR RELATIONS ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE.
BUT MEMBERS I WANNA FOCUS ON A
DIFFERENT PART OF.
AS CAESAR CHAVEZ'S LIFE THAT.
THOSE THAT KNEW HIM AND GREW UP
WITH HIM IN HIS TEACHINGS
REMEMBER ABOUT HIM THAT DON'T
ALWAYS GET HIGHLIGHTED.
ONE SUCH ASPECT WAS THE
TEACHINGS OF NONVIOLENCE
PERSEVERANCE HARD WORK.
AND JUST SEEING THE STRENGTH AND
OTHERS.
MEMBERS LEDGE ONCE YOU'RE A
COUPLE PERSONAL STORIES IF I MAY
STORIES THAT I'VE LEARNED OVER
THE YEARS.
TALKING WITH HIS SON PAUL
CHAVEZ WITH HIS GRANDSON WITH
IS.
WITH THAT.
THE CHáVEZ FAMILY IN THE
EXTENDED FAMILY OVER THE YEARS
AND ONE OF THE STORIES THAT
ALWAYS GETS HIGHLIGHTED TO BE.
IN THOSE PERSONAL INTERACTIONS
IS CESAR CHAVEZ'S ABILITY TO SEE
STRENGTHENED OTHERS.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WHAT DOES THAT ACTUALLY MEAN I
REMEMBER TALKING TO HIS SON AND
THE SON WAS TALKING ABOUT. YOU
KNOW MY FATHER SON ME STRENGTH
THAT I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT I
POSSESS.
HE PUT HIM IN CHARGE OF
POSITIONS AND IN CHARGE OF JOBS.
STARTING FROM A PRINTING PRESS.
AND DOING SOMETHING SO SMALL AND
SO MINUTE.
BUT HE THOUGHT IT WAS JUST A
BUT HOW THAT TRAIN HIM TO BE A
BETTER ORGANIZER IN A BETTER
LEADER AND UNDERSTAND THE ENTIRE
ORGANIZATION.
I YOU HEAR THE STORIES ABOUT
NONVIOLENCE
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE HEARING A
LOT ABOUT. TODAY IN TODAY'S
POLITICAL CLIMATE CLIMATE.
BUT THE FIGHT THAT WERE
OCCURRING DECADES AGO ABOUT
NONVIOLENCE.
THE FIGHTS OF THE ONLY WAY THEY
WILL LISTEN TO US IS IF WE
RESPOND WITH VIOLENCE BECAUSE
NOBODY IS LISTENING OTHERWISE.
AND CESAR USED TO TEACH HIS KIDS
HIS FAMILY AND EVERYBODY IN THE
MOVEMENT.
THAT YOU GET MORE ACCOMPLISHED
WITH NON VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO.
YOU GET MORE DONE WITH NON
VIOLENCE BECAUSE YOU DO NOT LET
HATE. CONTROL YOU.
YOUR ACTIONS AND THE SITUATION
AROUND YOU.
THOSE ARE LESSONS A BELIEVER
VERY PERTINENT FOR TODAY'S
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT.
THE OTHER.
THE OTHER THING THAT YOU WON'T
HEAR ABOUT OR READ ABOUT
PROBABLY TOO MUCH IN THE PAPERS.
BUT JUST GROWING UP IN THE AREA.
IS THE DEDICATION TO HARD WORK
AND PERSEVERANCE.
AND THE PERSEVERANCE IS ONE OF
THINGS I WANT HIGHLY BECAUSE WE
ALWAYS READ ABOUT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF CESAR CHAVEZ.
AND OF THE UNION BUT WE NEVER
HEAR ABOUT. THE LOSSES IN THE
HARD TIMES.
AND WHEN YOU TALK TO HIS FAMILY
YEAR TALK UP TO TALK TO PEOPLE
THAT GREW UP IN THE AREA.
THEY'LL TELL YOU ABOUT A LOT OF
TIMES.
WHEN THEY CAME UP ON THE SHORT
END OF THE STICK.
AND CESAR USED TO TELL HIS KIDS.
USED TO TELL THEM.
IF YOU FOUGHT AS HARD AS YOU
COULD FIGHT AND YOU DID
EVERYTHING THAT YOU COULD
POSSIBLY DO.
THE NEW DIDN'T LOSE.
THE ONLY TIME YOU LOSE IS WHEN
YOU GIVE UP HOPE.
WHEN YOU NO LONGER GET UP DUST
YOURSELF OFF.
WHICH IS YOU TO FIGHT FOR
ANOTHER DAY.
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE.
CESAR CHAVEZ PASSED AWAY.
AND OVER FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
MARCHED MINUS CASKET.
IN THE LANE L. OF FORTY ACRES.
AND CLOSE MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
CLOSE WITH A COUPLE OF THINGS.
ONE.
HIS WORDS I THINK HOLD TRUE TO
BE A.
AND TO MANY OF US HERE.
THAT ONE SOCIAL CHANGE BEGINS
THEY CANNOT BE REVERSED.
YOU CANNOT AND EDUCATE THE
PERSON WHO HAS LEARNED TO READ.
YOU CAN THAT.
YOU CANNOT HUMILIATE THE PERSON
WHO FILLS PRIDE.
YOU CANNOT OPPRESS THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT AFRAID ANYMORE.
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASK.
THAT THE ROLL BE OPEN FOR
COAUTHORS FOR AN AMERICAN HERO.
AN AMERICAN WHO SERVED HIS
COUNTRY BULLY HIS COUNTRY
HONORABLY IN THE U. S. NAVY.
AND WHO HAS BEEN AWARDED THE
MEDAL OF HONOR.
AND WAS ACTUALLY INDUCTED INTO
THE HALL OF FAME IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX BY.
A REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER.
SPEAKER ASSETS FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS MR
MCCARTY YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK.
GOOD USE OF IT JOINING
MICROPHONE THANK YOU MISSED
MCCARTY.
STAND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY
SIX IN REMEMBRANCE ASSESSOR
CHAVEZ.
IT'S REALLY IT WITH GREAT HONOR
THAT OUR STATE CELEBRATE THE
LEGACY ASSESSOR CHAVEZ.
A PROMINENT UNION LEADER A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND A GREAT
CALIFORNIAN.
HE'S OF COURSE REMEMBERED FOR IS
DEDICATED FIGHT TO GIVE A
DIGNIFIED SALARY AND SAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS.
FOR THOSE WHO PUT FOOD ON OUR
TABLE. AND OF COURSE HE WAS AN
ADVOCATE FOR THOSE WITHOUT A
VOICE.
SINCE OUR CHAVEZ FOUGHT FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
JUST LIKE THE LATE DOCTOR DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
BOTH LEE LEADERS WORK TO EXPAND
CIVIL RIGHTS
IN FACT DR KING SENSE UP SENT
CHAVEZ A TELEGRAM RECOGNIZING
NOT ONLY HIS WORK AS AN
ACTIVIST.
BUT TALKING ABOUT THAT JOINT.
SHARE COMMON GOALS OF THE BLACK
AND LATINO COMMUNITIES HE NOTED
THAT.
AND I QUOTE ARE SEPARATE
STRUGGLES ARE REALLY ONE A
STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM DIGNITY AND
HUMANITY.
AS LAWMAKERS AND CALIFORNIANS WE
MUST CONTINUE TO LEARN FROM HIS
LEGACY IN AS AN ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY.
AS WE READ.
IN THE HEADLINES TODAY MANY OF
THE SAME ISSUES FOR FIFTY YEARS
AGO WHEN HE WROTE THAT TELEGRAM.
OUR FRIEND CENTER TODAY WE MUST
CONTINUE TO FIGHT SO SISTER
CHAVEZ AND THE LEGACY CONTINUES
TO BLOOM FOR EVERY FARM WORKER
IN THE FIELDS OF CALIFORNIA. AND
FOR EVERY CAT COMMUNITY WITHIN
THE GREAT STATE WHICH WE LIVE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT HR EIGHTY
SIX
AND ASK FOR EVERYBODY JOIN AS A
CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY MAYES RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE JOYS CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY SIX IN
HONOR OF THE LATE CESAR CHAVEZ.
AS SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW THIS
WEEK MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH FAITH
AROUND THE WORLD ARE CELEBRATING
PASSOVER.
HOWEVER WHAT YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW
IS THAT EVERY EVEN THOUGH CESAR
CHAVEZ WITH THE CATHOLIC.
HE USED TO HOLD PASSOVER CEDARS
AT THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
HEADQUARTERS.
FOR THE CEREMONIAL HOLIDAY
DINNERS CHAVEZ WOULD INVITE
RABBIS FROM LA TO LA PAZ TO LEAD
HAS MEMBERS IMPAIR AND TO SHARE
THE STORY OF EXODUS WITH OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE UNFAMILIAR
WITH THE STORY OF EXODUS IT IS A
STORY OF LIBERATION THAT HAS
BEEN AN INSPIRATION TO MANY
SEEKING JUSTICE AND EQUALITY.
IN THIS STORY MOSES LEADS THE
ISRAELITES OUT OF SLAVERY AND
INTO FREEDOM TO THE PROMISED
LAND.
HAVING FOUGHT TIRELESSLY FOR
FAIR WORKING CONDITIONS EQUAITY
AND JUSTICE CHAVEZ WAS A
NATURAL.
WAS NATURALLY ALSO INSPIRED BY
THE STORY OF FREEDOM.
IN MEMORY OF THOMAS'S WORK AND
HIS CAMARADERIE WITH THE MEMBERS
OF THE JEWISH FAITH. I STRONGLY
URGE AND I VOTE FOR THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO MISTER
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF. HR EIGHTY SIX I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLACE
FOR TAKING THE LEAD IN
RECOGNIZING AND ICONIC
INDIVIDUAL IN OUR STATES IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY AND AN ONGOING.
STRUGGLE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE CHAVEZ
FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY LEADERSHIP
ORGANIZING CALIFORNIA'S
FARMWORKERS AND HELPING THEM IN
THEIR FIGHT.
FOR BETTER PAY AND BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS
DURING THE DELAY NO GRAPE STRIKE
OF THE NINETEEN SIXTIES AND
THEREAFTER SAYS ARE CHAVEZ
WORKED ALONGSIDE.
FILIPINO AMERICAN ACTIVISTS AND
LABOR LEADERS SUCH AS LARRY AT
LEON AND PHILIP VERA CRUZ IN
BUILDING COALITIONS TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND BEYOND
I SAW THIS COALITION FIRST HAND
AS I GREW UP IN THE UFW
HEADQUARTERS OF LA PAS WHILE MY
PARENTS WORKED ITS FORMER
ORGANIZERS. FOR THE UFW.
LET THE UNITY AND LEADERSHIP OF
THAT BEAUTIFUL COALITION BE A
REMINDER TO US ALL THAT WE MUST
OVERCOME OUR DIFFERENCES AND
COME TOGETHER IN THESE TIMES OF
UNCERTAINTY. AS WE CONFRONT
OFTEN EXCLUSIONARY AND DIVISIVE
POLICIES AND ACTIONS IN TODAY'S
WORLD.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF OUR
HR EIGHTY SIX IN HONORING THE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF SAYS ARE
JOBLESS.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA IS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. HONORING SAYS HOW
CHáVEZ.
SO FOR JOBS ONCE SAID.
WE CANNOT SEEK ACHIEVEMENT FOR
OURSELVES AND FORGET ABOUT
PROGRESS AND PROSPERITY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
OUR AMBITIONS MUST BE BROAD
ENOUGH TO INCLUDE THE
ASPIRATIONS AND NEEDS OF OTHERS.
FOR THEIR SAKE AND FOR OUR OWN.
SO IT'S NOT CHAVEZ TAUGHT US
THAT WE ARE NEVER TOO YOUNG TO
SERVE AND WORK HARD IN FACT HE
STARTED WORKING WHEN HE WAS TEN
YEARS OLD TO HELP HIS FAMILY.
WITH THIS MINDSET HE FORGED A
LEGACY OF SERVICE JOINED IN
LEADERSHIP BY POWERFUL. WOMEN S.
PASAS EACH PASS IT AMONG US MY
MOUSE AND PS.
THAT MAY JUSTICE POSSIBLE.
WITH THE EFFORTS OF COUNTLESS
POWERFUL WOMEN HE USED HIS
LEADERSHIP SKILLS AND HIS LOVE
FOR PEOPLE. TO HELP TRANSFORM
THE COMMUNITY FROM THE GROUND
UP.
THE SERVICE WE PROVIDE TO OUR
COMMUNITY NOT ONLY IMPACTS OUR
LIVES BUT ALSO THE LIVES OF
THOSE WE LOVE AND SERVE.
ON THIS DAY LET US REMEMBER THE
LEADERSHIP OF SO SOME CHAVEZ AND
THE NUMEROUS WOMEN. INCLUDING
MOST ESPECIALLY THE LOTUS
HUERTA.
THAT WERE POWERED TO FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE.
I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT IT'S VERY
FITTING THAT WE HAVE ON THAT AS
BONTA WITH US TODAY.
ON THAT'S CHAVEZ SO SO TRAVIS IS
GRANDSON HAS BEEN OF ONE OF THE
MOST OUTSPOKEN OF THE CHáVEZ
FAMILY AND WAS WITH US THIS
WEEKEND. AND I SALUTE HIM FOR
GOING TO ENGLAND CONTINUING HIS
GRANDFATHER'S LEGACY.
SO IN THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I'D
VOTE OF. H. R. EIGHTY SIX THANK
YOU.
TAKING THIS RACE
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I AM MOVED TO RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
JOINT IN YOU IS WE GET A FEW
MINUTES AGO IN SUPPORT OF THE
MLK. OBSERVANCE.
.
WHEN I THINK OF THE TEMPESTUOUS
TIMERS
THE BOTH OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
FOUND THEMSELVES AND.
IN SOME RESPECTS NOT UNLIKE SOME
OF OUR OWN TIMES HERE IN OUR
NATION TODAY.
HEARING SACRAMENTO'S SEE IN
RECENT WEEKS.
I THINK IT TO BE PRESENT THOSE
TIMES IS TO BECOME AWARE OF.
AN OUTCRY AND THE DISRUPTION ANY
TENSION WHICH
CAPTIVATES ONE'S INTEREST.
AND STIRRERS ONE'S REFLECTIONS
UPON WHAT WE ALL ABOUT WHAT IS.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
AND I WOULD JUST ONE OR
KNOWLEDGE THAT THESE SORTS OF
CONVERSATIONS WHEN THEY HAPPEN
IN OUR NATION.
ARE VERY AMERICAN CONVERSATIONS.
THEY ARE VERY FUNDAMENTAL TO THE
MEANING OF AMERICA.
AND THEY'RE VERY ASPIRATIONAL
ALTHOUGH WE TODAY ARE LOOKING
BACK.
THE REAL MEANING IS LOOKING
FORWARD.
AND JUST TO.
PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON THAT
PERMISSION TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
FROM A DOCUMENT ADOPTED ON JULY
FOURTH SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE SELF
EVIDENT.
MEANING INCONTESTABLE.
NO ONE COULD DISPUTE THEM.
THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
THAT THEIR ENDOWED BY THEIR
CREATOR.
I SAY ON THIS DAY AFTER EASTER.
THEY ARE ENDOWED BY THEIR
CREATOR INVESTED.
BY THEIR CREATOR ALL MEN AND
WOMEN.
ENDOWED BY THEIR CREATOR WITH
CERTAIN UNALIENABLE RIGHTS.
WHICH IS TO SAY THESE ARE RIGHTS
THAT NO ONE CAN TRANSFER.
THAT'S THE LAWYER IN ME.
I'M ALIENABLE RIGHTS.
IN DOWN BY THEIR CREATOR WITH
CERTAIN INALIENABLE RIGHTS IF
THEY CANNOT TRANSFER AWAY.
NOR.
ACCORDING THIS DOG WOULD DO WE
HAVE ANY RIGHT EXPECTING PEOPLE
TO SURRENDER THOSE RIGHTS.
TO ACT AS IF THEY DO NOT POSSESS
THOSE RIGHTS.
CONDUCT THEMSELVES AS ALL THE
ARE SUBJECT TO SOME DIFFERENT
STANDARD THAN THEIR NEIGHBOR.
ENDOWED BY THEIR CREATOR WITH
CERTAIN UNALIENABLE RIGHTS THAT
AMONG THESE ARE LIFE LIBERTY AND
THE PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
THESE.
TITANS WHO WE ARE ON THE FLOOR
TODAY.
WERE REALLY STAND IT UP.
IN DEFENSE OF PEOPLE.
AND THEIR UNALIENABLE RIGHTS.
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE THE FULL
EXERCISE OF THOSE RIGHTS.
AND THIS WAS A PART OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
TO RESIDE IN AMERICA.
TO NOT HAVE SOCIETY ACT AS IF
YOU MUST SURRENDER.
IN A THESE VALUED.
PORTIONS OF YOUR HERITAGE.
AND I KNOW TO THOMAS JEFFERSON
WHO ACTUALLY PENNED THESE WORDS
WENT ON TO SAY.
THAT TO SECURE THESE RIGHTS
GOVERNMENTS ARE INSTITUTED AMONG
MEN.
DERIVING THEIR JUST POWERS
THINKS SO THE GOVERN.
THAT WHENEVER ANY FORM OF
GOVERNMENT BECOMES DESTRUCTIVE
DESTRUCTIVE TO THE SYRIANS.
THE DOES NOT FURTHER THESE.
THE ACQUISITION IN THE EXERCISE
OF THESE RIGHTS.
IT IS THE RIGHT OF THE PEOPLE TO
ALTER OR ABOLISH IT.
WHICH IS WHY THESE CONVERSATIONS
STARTED OUR SOCIETY.
PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER
THESE RIGHTS ARE BEING.
SURRENDER.
OR IN SOME WAY BEEN DESTROYED OR
HINDER.
A. RIGHT OF THE PEOPLE TO ALTER
OR ABOLISH IT IS HER NEW
GOVERNMENT LAYING ITS
FOUNDATION.
ON SUCH PRINCIPLES AND
ORGANIZING ITS POWERS IN SUCH
FORM AS TO THEM SHALL SEEM MOST
LIKELY TO EFFECT THEIR SAFETY
AND HAPPINESS.
SO WE HONOR THESE AS I SAY GREAT
TITANS.
OF THE AMERICAN VERSION OF.
OUR DEMOCRACY.
OF THESE UNALIENABLE RIGHTS
WHICH WE SHOULDNOT BE. WITHHELD.
CANNOT BE TRANSFERRED
AND NO ONE IS ENTITLED TO THINK
THAT SOMEONE WOULD SURRENDER
THEIR.
INDEED IT IS OUR JOB TO UPHOLD
THEIR EXERCISE.
AND SO WE.
WE ARE GREAT AREAS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE IN THE FACE OF A TIME WHEN.
SOME WAS ACCUSTOMED THINK IT'S
SOMEONE DID NOT ANSWERS.
THIS QUALITY OF RIGHT
TO ASSERT THAT RIGHT TO ADVOCATE
FOR.
AND IT IS A LESSON OF HISTORY
LESSON FOR OUR NATION GOING
FORWARD.
AND IT'S IN STANDING UP FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE LEGITIMACY. A.
REVEALS ITSELF.
AND A LOT A RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY. MR MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
FIFTY TWO YEARS AGO TO THE DAY.
ON EASTER SUNDAY.
SAYS OUR JOB IS TO THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS ENDED. THEIR THREE
HUNDRED.
SEVEN THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILE TRACK.
FROM DELANO.
TO SACRAMENTO.
A MARCH THAT BEGAN WITH SEVENTY
SEVEN PROTESTERS.
BY THE TIME THEY GOT TO
SACRAMENTO WAS THOUSANDS.
AND WHEN SET SIR MARCH TO
SACRAMENTO ON EASTER SUNDAY.
ALTHOUGH HE WAS FIGHTING FOR THE
RIGHTS OF FARM WORKERS.
AND THE WORK THAT HE DID CHANGE
THE LIVES OF FARM WORKERS.
IT NOT ONLY CHANGED THE LIVES OF
FARM WORKERS.
SO SO CHAVEZ WAS AN EXAMPLE.
HE WAS AN EXAMPLE TO THE YOUNG
LATINO STUDENTS.
I IN CALIFORNIA.
IT WE ASSESSORS CHAVEZ EXAMPLE
AND PRIDE IN HIS.
MEXICAN US
HERITAGE AND CULTURE.
THAT.
ENTHUSIAST.
OF YOUNG.
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
I COME APART AND TAKE PART.
IN THE CHICANO MOVEMENT.
SO ALTHOUGH WE CELEBRATE AND
RECOGNIZE MOSTLY SASSER FOR HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE OF WORK OF IMPROVING
FARMWORKERS I THINK THE OTHER
ALSO NEEDS TO BE RECOGNIZED.
AND AS WE HAVE STREETS.
STATUES
NAMED AFTER SAYS ARE CHAVEZ
I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LEARNED OF THE WORK
OBSESSIVE CHAVEZ AND THE LOTUS
WHAT THE.
SO I RISE.
SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY SIX.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
ESTHER SOLACE YOU MAKE CLOTHES
IF YOU WISH.
THINK THIS SPEAKER I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FOR A HUMBLE PUBLIC SERVANT TO.
JUST TRY TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
SO MANY IN OUR STATE AND ACROSS
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
ALSO THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
COOPERS.
EVEREST FIRST ROLES GOING TO BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THIS IS CO
AUTHORS ON HR EIGHTY SIX CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
COOPER IS MEMBERS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX
COAUTHORS ADDED. WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT HR EIGHTY SIX
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT. CONSENT
CALENDAR.
HAS ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND ACTUALLY THE
ESTATES AND TRUSTS.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS
ON
HIS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
IN THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE RURAL.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TO THIRTY SIX I SEVENTY NO ZERO
HOUSE RESOLUTION.
THREE I SEVENTY NO ZERO.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO AND DECEMBER.
RESOLUTE
AND SEVENTEEN
I SEVENTY THOSE ZERO.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS WE ARE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENT.
IN MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES.
WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS OR GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
DR.
EGGMAN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ENJOYMENT IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY HIGH RISE IN.
THE US WITH THAT WE ADJOURNED
AND THE MEMORY OF REVERSE
FLORES.
IS BORN JANUARY THIRTEENTH
NINETEEN THIRTY AND DIED MARCH
EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
PASSED AWAY QUIETLY IN HIS SLEEP
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY WHO
WERE CARING FOR HIM AT THE END
OF HIS LIFE.
HE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND LIVED
HIS ENTIRE LIFE THERE ONE OF
THE.
NEW GENERATIONS THAT CAME UP IN
THE LATINO COMMUNITY BECAME
PROFESSIONALS.
YOU WAS A SURVEYOR AND HE HAD A
SON GARY START A COMPANY AND. I
JEAN ARE DELTA LAND PLANNING AND
AND RAN THAT COMPANY.
.
HE ALSO ENJOYED COACHING SON'S
BASEBALL IS A HUGE SPORTS FAN
FISHING AND HUNTING.
ATTENDING SPORTS AND OTHER
EVENTS.
HE LOVED HIS FAMILY HIS
GRANDCHILDREN HIS CHILDREN.
SUNDAY BREAKFAST
ROOM GATHERED AROUND THE TABLE
TO HOLD THE WHOLE FAMILY AND HE
TAUGHT AS CHILDREN ABOUT
INDEPENDENCE HUMILITY AND THE
VALUE OF HAVING EDUCATION.
I'M HONORED TO BE CLOSE FRIENDS
WITH HIS DAUGHTER WHO SERVES ON
THE DELTA COLLEGE TRUSTEE JANET
RIVERO'S BUT WHEN THE LONGEST
SERVING. A TRUSTEES DEL THE
COLLEGES HAD AS WELL AS ONE OF
THE FIRST LATINO US TO BE ABLE
TO HOLD THAT POSITION.
SHE WAS THE CAREGIVER AT THE END
OF HIS LIFE AND HE WILL LONG BE
REMEMBERED FOR HIS GENEROSITY.
HIS LOVE HIS ENCOURAGEMENT OF
HIS FAMILY AND COMMUNITY TO BE
ALL THEY COULD BE.
TO MAKE THE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY THE PLACE THAT WE CAN
ALL.
A PROUD OF SO MEMBERS I ASK THAT
IN THE MEMORY TODAY A REVERSE
FLORES.
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
ON THIS DAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
ROBERT BOB MANLEY.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF SEIU
LOCAL THREE FORMER FORTY SEVEN
RETIREES AND WHO WAS A GREAT
MENTOR AND DEAR FRIEND TO ME.
BOB WAS BORN INTO WHAT'S
DISTRICT OF LOS ANGELES
BOB ATTENDED FORTY NINTH ST
GRADE SCHOOL GEORGE WASHINGTON
CARVER JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL AND
THOMAS JEFFERSON HIGH SCHOOL
WHICH ARE CALLED THE DEMOCRATS
AND.
BIG BOB WAS A BIG BIG DE
DEMOCRATS.
WHILE ATTENDING CARVER JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOL. BOB BELONG TO THE
NIGHT IN THE LEADERSHIP CLASS
AND IT WAS THAT LEADERSHIP CLASS
TO HELP. HIM DEVELOP INTO A
GREAT LEADER FOR THE REST OF HIS
LIFE. WHILE SERVING UNITED
STATES AIRFORCE BOB BECAME MORE
AWARE OF THE WORLD AND ITS
INJUSTICES AND DECIDED THAT THE
POLITICAL PROCESS WAS A WAY TO
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS.
BOB POLITICAL INVOLVEMENT BEGAN
WORKING FOR FORMER CITY
COUNCILMEN AND LATER MAYOR OF
LOS ANGELES TOM BRADLEY IN HIS
ELECTION. DID TEND COUNCIL
DISTRICT.
BOB ALSO WORK VERY HARD TO
DEFEAT PROP FOURTEEN WHICH WHICH
A REPEAL OF THE RUMFORD FAIR
HOUSING LAW.
BOB WAS VERY INVOLVED IN MANY
ELECTION CAMPAIGNS THAT FOLLOWED
INCLUDING BILL CLINTON ED
JOHNSON MICHAEL WOO JAMES HAHN
AND SEVERAL OTHERS.
BOB ALSO WORKED AS THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR OF SEIU LOCAL THREE
FOUR SEVEN. ELATED LATER AS
DISTRICT DIRECTOR FOR FORMER
ASSEMBLYMAN JEROME HORTON.
I DO THOUSAND FOUR BOB WAS
APPOINT A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTOR
BY UNITED STATES SENATOR BARBARA
BOXER. BOB WAS ALSO A TRUE
LEADER IN THE COMMUNITY COACHING
AT ALL LEVELS FROM GRADE SCHOOL
TO COLLEGE AND MINOR LEAGUE
PROFESSIONAL TEAMS.
THERE ARE MANY SUCCESSFUL YOUNG
MEN DOUBLE COACH BY BOB SOME OF
WHOM WENT ON TO PLAY
PROFESSIONAL FOOTBALL.
BOB.
WAS A TRUE PROGRESSIVE.
BOB WAS PROGRESSIVE WHEN IT
WASN'T FASHIONABLE BAB WAS
LIBERAL LITTLE LIBERAL WHEN MOST
PEOPLE RAN AWAY FROM IT.
BOB WAS A TRUE PROGRESSIVE AND
FOUGHT FOR EVERY PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA.
BOB IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE SHOT
DOWN.
HIS FIVE CHILDREN.
SIX GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
HERE MISTER JONES SAWYER.
AND MISTER.
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I RISE TO IN GERMAN AND MEMORY
OF PATRICIA GARDNER. FROM
BISHOP.
PATRICIA PASSED AWAY ON MARCH
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
PAT GARDNER SERVED ON THE BISHOP
CITY COUNCIL FOR NEARLY SIX
YEARS.
SHE WAS ELECTED TO SERVE ON THE
CITY COUNCIL.
FOR A FOUR YEAR TERM ON NOVEMBER
SIXTH.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND WAS
REELECTED TO ANOTHER FOUR YEAR
TERM.
IN NOVEMBER.
EIGHTH TWENTY SIXTEEN. WHILE
SERVING ON THE CITY COUNCIL PAT
SERVED AS MAYOR.
FROM DECEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY
FOURTEEN THROUGH DECEMBER
FOURTEENTH TWENTY FIFTEEN.
SHE SERVED AS MAYOR PRO TEMPORE.
FROM DECEMBER NINTH TWENTY
THIRTEEN THROUGH DECEMBER EIGHTH
TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND AGAIN FROM DECEMBER
ELEVENTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE DATE OF HER
PASSING.
THIS MARCH TWENTY FOURTH.
PAT WAS ALSO VERY ACTIVE IN HER
COMMUNITY AND FREAK ONLY
ATTENDED MEETINGS AND SUPPORTED
THE BISHOP CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND VISITORS BUREAU. AND THE
ANNUAL ASSOCIATES.
PAT WAS ALSO A PRIVATE BUSINESS
OWNER.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX HE
PURCHASED SPORTS MEDICINE AND
REHAB THERAPY AND CONTINUE THAT
PRACTICE.
AND TELL TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
SHE WAS ACTIVE IN THE UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH WHERE SHE
ENJOYED TEACHING SUNDAY SCHOOL.
SERVING ON GOVERNOR AND
COMMITTEES.
AND SUPPORTED THE PROGRAMS OF
THE UNITED METHODIST SOCIAL
SERVICES.
SHE ALSO VOLUNTEERED HER
SERVICES TO HOSPICE OF THE OWENS
VALLEY.
NOW PART OF PIONEER HOME HEALTH
CARE INCORPORATED.
SHE WAS THANKFUL TO WAKE UP EACH
DAY TO THE BEAUTIFUL SUNRISES.
OVER THE WHITE MOUNTAINS INTO
ANY EACH DAY.
WITH A VIEW OF THE GLORIOUS
SUNSETS OVER THE SIERRAS.
SHE WILL BE SORELY MISSED.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS.
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY APRIL THIRD CHECK IN
SESSION.
WEDNESDAY APRIL FOURTH CHECK IN
THURSDAY APRIL FIFTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
SURE TING MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL FIFTH.
AND NINE AM.
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED